carrasco gave up three runs in the first
three innings against the dodgers friday
night but then he retired his last eight
batters and that was very encouraging as
he was able to stretch out to 78
pitchers as ronnie mentioned and five
full innings for the first time this
year 1-1 pitch there's a swing and
there's a liner into shallow right field
and that's going to drop for a base hit
it had enough on it to get over the head
of the second baseman buyers who was
playing in shallow right field for wade
in the overshift one out with the runner
at first and here is chris bryant bryant
had his 23rd home run last night and it
was a long one he swings at the first
pitch and crushes one to left field for
the second game in a row bryant goes
deep and the giants are on the board
first two nothing 24th of the year sixth
with the giants one-two pitch swung on
and missed strike three a fast ball
running in and four carrasco his first
strikeout two men away there's the 0-1
wrapped back to the mound grabbed on one
hop by carrasco throws to first in time
side retired but in the inning for the
giants two runs two hits no errors
nobody left and in the middle of the
first inning it's the giants two and the
mets coming up what is ten and four with
an era of 4.11 he hits a lot of batters
nimo seven-game hitting streak which
remarkably matches his career high
nimmo takes the win the other way and
he's got a lead off hit
and brandon continues to rake against
the lefties came into the night 349
against left-hand pitching second best
among left-hand hitters in baseball and
he's got a base hit to start this one
now a slider struck him out a swinging
strike three a ball right in on the
hands inning over shut down inning for
wood so here is jaspremski who was oh
for two last night here's the 02. swung
on and missed strike three good change
up from carrasco who picks up his second
strikeout so two men away kurt casale
will be the better here's the payoff
pitch
kasali lines it to right pillar took a
step in now a couple back and makes the
catch at his left shoulder with one hand
to retire the side nothing across middle
of the second the giants two the mets
nothing let's have runners at first and
second one out for patrick mazzeka
on the ground to short should be two but
a little bobble and so crawford takes
the out at first seemed like he was
looking to go to second but listello was
a little late to get over and as you
said didn't want to mess around the o2
pitch swing and the miss he struck him
out wood gets through it slide away off
the inside and down
two out of stone at a second here's
brian who jumped on the first pitch
slider and hit one into the seats in
left field two-two coming and bryant
chases a slider for strength three
breaking ball down and away and bryant
expanded his zone badly to chase after
it so carrasco gets his third strikeout
brandon nemo who like dom smith has hit
better against lefties this year now he
swings and misses at a fastball right in
under the hands strike three third
strikeout for alex woodman
tops that one toward third tough play
for bryant with the bare hand and the
throw not quite in time and lendora's
got his first hit since coming off the
injured list here's the o2 pitch slider
slow chop the short crawford over to his
left has it the second one lestella back
to first
two a double play the inning is over
lonzo leads off the home fourth two and
two of the pitch alonzo lines toward
right base hit off the end of his bet
has reached out on a change up down and
away and poked a single to right field
third hit against alex wood and now
dominic smith will be here's a swing at
a ground ball toward the middle
crawford's got it he's gonna run to the
bag at second for one and throw to first
in time double play
another one got two in the first four
innings tonight
bellar left field just a high lazy fly
dickerson just like that ending over
roscoe's only given up three hits two of
them in the first inning including
brian's two run homer one two on the way
swinging a high fly ball to left pretty
deep smith going back into the corner on
the track near the wall he jumped and
did he make the catch he did in foul
territory out of our immediate range but
a nice catch made by dom smith for the
second out the 01 lined in the air to
right back goes polaris there and he
makes the one hand catch side retired
for carrasco seven in a row as the
giants go in order as the giants begin
their third time through the batting
order against carlos has only given up
three hits two run homer to bryant in
the first inning the only scoring so far
one two on the way swing and a mess and
a changeup strike three
carresco with his fourth strikeout one
out nobody on for tommy la stella 3-2 to
le stella and he rockets that one toward
right center but overcomes pilar to dive
and make the catch
well pilar can still cover ground he's
such a good outfielder you know and he's
played right field center field and the
stella with a nice at bat here that ball
was ripped but just a beautiful play by
pilar and so there are two men away
nicely done by kevin palar brian chases
one for strike three mazika will have to
make the toss down to first and that
retires the side five strikeouts for
carrasco's retired ten in a row it's the
32nd time that they've been held
scoreless for the first five innings 1-2
lindor strikes out swinging great slider
from wood
out number one
five strikeouts for alex wood here's the
one-two swing on the grounder up the
middle pass crawford base hit left
center field baez around first he's
going to try it the throw by estremskey
way offline head first slide byas is
safe stays on the bag they won't review
that it's a hustle double for javier
baez
the mitz for the sixth consecutive
inning have at least one runner on base
alonzo was struck out single to right
he's the tying man at the plate now and
there it goes deep to left if it's fair
it's gone it's right down the line
and it is a home run
pete alonso right down the line a long
home run a two-run shot and this game is
all even the giants two in the midst two
number 29 for pete alonso well that's
going to be the end of the line for alex
wood alonso's home run ties up the game
and now the giants will go to the
bullpen 3-1
is hit high in the air really a pop-up
to shortstop crawford went back now he
comes in and makes the catch
the inning is over and that's leave the
go-ahead run in scoring position but
they tie the game on pete alonso's own
run carlos carrasco keeps on rolling
he's retired 11 straight 1-1 pitch
swinging a grounder to third again off
the bat of flores vr's got this one
sidearm throw to first in time as
carrasco sits down crawford and flores
and now the left-handed batting alex
dickerson will bat he's over two
dickerson grounded out his last time
first pitch bounced this one to the
right side baez has it takes a step
throw to first in time carlos carrasco
has been excellent tonight he has
retired 13 in a row he's allowed just
one hit since the bryant home run in the
first inning seven sparkly hittings seth
lugo out of the mets bullpen for the
second straight night runners at first
and second nobody out and darren ruff
announced as the pinch hitter for garcia
1-1 on the ground and nobody's there
into right field base hit pilar up with
the ball here comes yastremski the throw
is offline it goes right over the
catcher the giants have gone ahead three
to two and they're set up for more here
in the eighth inning lugo faces three
batters working a second straight night
doesn't retire anybody so the base has
loaded nobody out trump is at third
rough at second slater at first 3-2 from
luke and estrada pounds one slowly tough
play vr scooping it home and he gets the
force
nicely done by jonathan vr
knew he didn't have time to make the
transfer and the advantage of a
relatively slow runner coming down the
line and gets the pinch runner trump on
the force for the first out this is just
a fine play quick reaction here's the
2-2 pitch swung out and missed strike
three got him with a fastball
this is huge for aaron loop now two men
away 2-1 pitch crawford pops it up
shallow left vr out smith in vr under it
makes the catch and that retires the
side oh what a job by aaron luke the
let's have the bases loaded and here
comes jeff mcneal out of the dugout he's
going to bet from patrick mozika 02
pitch
ground ball to short right to coffee
here's the throw to first he got him
alvarez does it again the second time
in as many nights that he has retired
jeff mcneal with the bases loaded well
tyler rogers is fishing more games than
any pitcher in the national league this
year shootout nobody on the pitch julian
door
swing and there's a high fly ball coming
into medium right center yaz is under it
and he's got it and the ball game is
over they take five out of six from the
mets over these last couple weeks
you